good it's brutal out here olivia rodrigo
is giving us gen z realness in her pop
punk anthem brutal and we'd love to see
it it's fantastic on monday the 18 year
old singer released the music video for
the latest single off her debut studio
album sour where she sings about her
life in the spotlight playing a news
anchor reporting on her own teen angst
thinking i'm so caught up in the news of
who likes me and who hates you and i'm
so tired that i might quit my job start
a new life and they'd all be so
disappointed because who am i if not
exploited the pop star also pokes fun at
influencer culture using several fun
animations and filters throughout the
video and this all too familiar
instagram feature seemingly apologizing
to her haters
[Music]
it's brutal out here but the best moment
hands down was olivia seemingly
recreating this look paying homage to
britney spears in 2003 wearing this
identical corset dress by roberto
cavalli draped in chiffon and beaded
fringe
[Music]
earlier this summer brutal peaked at
number 12 on the billboard hot 100 along
with her album sour which debuted at
number one on the billboard hot 200
after its release in may
[Music]
now olivia is set to perform at the 2021
mtv video music awards next month and
last year et spoke with the pop star who
reflected on how much she's grown in her
music career obviously getting to write
for the show is such an amazing
opportunity and getting to write
something that you know will be like
heard by people is obviously kind of a
lot of pressure but i think made me
better as a songwriter totally and
writing to prompt is something that i'm
really trying to get used to like being
like okay this is what i have to write
about and this is all the points that i
have to touch on that's something that i
never really did before i kind of just
wrote what i was feeling and so it's
kind of nice to be able to write
something from a more structured
approach but uh yeah immensely grateful
for everything that the show has taught
me it's it's really infinite
[Music]
to start
[Music]